[Música]
y avanzamos a nuestro primer invitado
del día el primer papa latinoamericano
de la historia cumple 10 años siendo el
máximo líder de la Iglesia Católica el
13 de marzo de 2013 Jorge Mario
bergoglio adoptó el nombre de Papa
Francisco su corriente jesuita con
enfoque además franciscano marcaron una
diferencia frente a la línea más
conservadora de la iglesia y de su
predecesor Benedicto 16 vamos a analizar
esta década de papado y nos acompaña
Marcial Sánchez gaete él Es doctor en
historia y también experto en historia
de la Iglesia Católica Muchísimas
gracias Marcial Bienvenido a directo a
América
muy buenos días gracias por la
invitación acá estamos bueno
quizá el mayor reto que enfrenta el Papa
Francisco tiene que ver con la
pederastia y con los crímenes contra
menores por miembros de la Iglesia
Católica Alemania Francia y Portugal han
adelantado investigaciones
independientes que hablan de cerca de
225.000 abusos sexuales cometidos por
clérigos o por miembros de la del
organigrama de la iglesia Aunque el
propio Papa Francisco ha dicho que ha
hecho esfuerzos muy grandes para reparar
estos daños como sigue golpeando El
crimen de la pederastia y del abuso
sexual a la iglesia católica Que tanto
se ha hecho de verdad para revertir o
para reparar estos delitos
a ver el Papa Francisco toma posesión el
2013 en marzo el 13 de marzo del 2013
han pasado diez años diez años que
pareciera que fueran mucho más tiempo y
uno de los grandes problemas es este el
tema de la pederastia dentro de la
Iglesia Católica los abusos de poder de
conciencia sexuales como el mismo ha
planteado
él ha hecho lo posible en cuanto a dar
las normativas suficientes y necesarias
para poder seguir los conductos primero
para que los casos agilicen mucho más
segundo las normativas para que
efectivamente los casos lleguen al
Vaticano y se tome se juzgue sobre ellos
y tercero
tratar de juntar el elemento civil con
elemento canónico de alguna forma
diciendo que cualquier caso este tema
debe ser conocido por la por la justicia
penal o Civil del lugar donde se cometió
el abuso yo creo que Francisco ha
avanzado en ese plano pero un tema es lo
que está escrito y otro otro tema en lo
que realmente sucede en diferentes
diócesis yo soy un convencido que hoy
día están dadas todas las condiciones
para que las diócesis empiecen a hacer
lo correcto lo que tienen que hacer no
Porque el papa lo diga sino porque
efectivamente esta iglesia católica se
ha alejado
bastante o mucho o varios sus miembros
de lo que significaba lo correcto en
este plano los abusos sexuales y además
de menores de edad Como lo han denotado
los las investigaciones que tú has
planteado
en algunos aspectos el Papa Francisco ha
querido mostrar una postura más liberal
y renovada de la Iglesia Católica por
ejemplo hablando del respeto de la unión
civil de personas del mismo sexo
diciendo que una persona de la comunidad
diversa tiene derecho a una familia sin
embargo Eso no significa que los acepten
realmente dentro de la Iglesia Católica
en esa condición por otro lado
recientemente criticó el celibato que
deben guardar los sacerdotes y las
monjas en el catolicismo Pero eso no
significa que cambie el dogma es decir
es una forma de decir yo los respeto
ustedes existen Y eso es un
reconocimiento importante frente a la
historia de la Iglesia Católica pero en
el fondo Pues la Iglesia Católica cree
usted que sí ha cambiado o sigue siendo
la misma finalmente Si una persona de la
comunidad diversa quisiera comulgar
siendo confeso Pues de su de su
orientación pues no podría hacerlo
la iglesia sigue siendo la misma
lo que pasa es que hay intenciones hay
una postura que tiene este pontífice
pero para poder llevarla de adelanto
Obviamente que tiene que haber una
reforma y No necesariamente un mutuo
propio muto propio para que la gente
entienda es un mandato de él
directamente tiene que ir un poco más
allá tiene que conversarlo con los
Cardenales probablemente tiene una
votación una comisión en fin lo
importante creo yo que hay una
más que ganas realmente hay una postura
que él tiene frente a ciertos temas y
esa postura tiene que canalizarse pero
esta postura no se ha canalizado ahora
bien de papa liberal o conservador Yo
creo que es un papa que se ha colocado
en el signo del tiempo una de las
gracias que tiene Francisco y que
nosotros hemos visto en estos diez años
que uno es uno de los líderes a nivel
mundial que es capaz de leer muy bien el
signo del tiempo es decir colocarse la
realidad ahora el mundo el mundo como tú
lo planteabas estos
que efectivamente son reconocidos por la
iglesia católica
al margen de ser reconocidos y al margen
de ser aceptados el papa tiene muy claro
que es parte de una realidad integrada
al mundo occidental hoy día y la iglesia
no puede no puede seguir
colocándolos al lado y no solamente
ellos sino también al mundo los
divorciados en fin son varios elementos
y yo creo que el papa está dando signos
que ese es el cambio que tiene que venir
el mismo tema del celibato él lo dijo
clarito muy muy claro que efectivamente
en occidente teníamos El problema del
celibato pero no en Oriente yo creo que
Francisco está mirando una iglesia unida
la iglesia católica de Oriente y la
Iglesia Católica occidente una sola de
acuerdo en base a ciertos temas y en lo
último que tiene que ver con los dogmas
Ninguno de los temas planteados por por
ti Ahora son dogmas los dogmas no se
atrasan de acuerdo Los dogmas no se
cambian Pero estas han sido costumbres
que han sido asumidas en el tiempo el
caso por ejemplo de la homosexualidad
viene del mil cuatrocientos pero es una
normativa impuesta por un papa y
Asimismo también puede ser efectivamente
como el muy el dijo Es una normativa que
puede efectivamente la iglesia
considerar en su momento no seguir
aplicándola en el mundo occidental Usted
cree que los sectores más conservadores
de la iglesia son los que impiden que
lleguen esas modificaciones
absolutamente de acuerdo en eso y más
aún hay sectores conservadores dentro de
la iglesia que han dicho que el papa se
ha alejado del dogma
fundamentalmente por las dos encíclicas
y una en específico de acuerdo en donde
el papa dice que estamos viviendo en un
mundo capitalista neoliberal en donde el
individualismo cruza de acuerdo ya habla
de las curvas de oferta y las curvas de
demanda
él él es muy directo en decir las en dar
cuenta que efectivamente hoy día el
dinero Norma más la vida que la
problemática moral y esos son elementos
que efectivamente para ciertos
conservadores
eso eso le le ha traído más de algún
problema y más aún la forma que
Francisco es como persona también en
cuanto a su modo de ser personal Esto va
a acercarse más a la prensa de conversar
con ellos de de utilizar
ciertas formas que eran tradicionales de
acuerdo y él las ha cambiado en fin de
acuerdo y eso obviamente hay sectores
que no no están muy de acuerdo Bueno
pero es lo que demandan los tiempos y de
todas maneras Muchas cuentas pendientes
tienen la Iglesia Católica Marcial
gracias a usted por su análisis esa
Marcial Sánchez gaete doctor en historia
y experto en historia de la iglesia
católica que tenga un feliz día
igual usted que estén muy bien a
nuestros televidentes sigan en directo
América ya volvemos
[Música]